afternoon or wherever you might be in
the world i hope everyone is doing well
and i want to thank you for taking the
time to
visit our presentation
my name is steve friedland i am the
director of volumetric services for
ortho clinical diagnostics
and our presentation today is how we
help ortho clinical diagnostics
customers achieve the highest levels of
efficiency
so what i'd like to do is just uh
from an agenda perspective i tell you a
little bit about who we are at
volumetric services
give you some idea of how we do what we
do
i will talk a little bit about lean
basics
and then what success looks like and and
do uh one particular case study and then
we'll end by uh perhaps how you might
benefit and also uh i will allow time
for
questions and answers uh if you have
questions there's a tab at the bottom q
a if you type them in i'll be able to
see them if i'm able i'll do them real
time uh if not i will uh do the q a
session at the end so we'll see how that
goes
so i think everybody would admit admit
no matter where we are around the globe
we have lots of challenges in health
care
and these clearly are global uh
obviously people which is the most
important part of any enterprise or any
business and that's finding the right
staff
retaining the staff
and obviously in many markets around the
globe the cost of labor continues to go
up
so
the right people
is probably the most important
ingredient in any good operation
i don't have to speak too much about
performance demands turnaround time
obviously we're getting increased
volumes as we add more and more people
to uh the roles of those that are
seeking and receiving health care
customer satisfaction is taking a role
front and center in how systems get
measured
and also
physician satisfaction and obviously
with the genome and molecular
diagnostics we have much more complexity
in our testing environment
in terms of the business of health care
uh depending on the market you're in
this lower or no reimbursements
obviously is in the fee for service
markets but in other markets as well
with single-payer or multi-payer systems
still
lower doing doing more with less is the
name of the game in terms of
reimbursement
facilities
this doesn't get talked about a lot but
in many many places we have space
constraints uh original and and
traditional lab layout and design uh has
been challenged on many fronts lean does
this actually quite a bit and as we've
added newer instruments more instruments
and
larger footprint instruments facilities
has become a real issue in many uh
places in many markets around the
country
and then uh obviously just to summarize
our challenges and this is true globally
i'm sure we have to find ways to do more
work at a higher level of quality yet we
have to find ways to continuously reduce
our cost of operation
so a little bit about volumetric
services
we were formed in 2001
and we started bringing lean both lean
and six sigma applications into clinical
labs
we actually used a model
that was developed internally at johnson
and johnson uh by their process
excellence organization
and that model really is teaching it's a
teaching training or a learn do model
knowledge transfer
is part of what we deliver a client so
we
learn or teach
clients through cycles of learning and
they're able to
implement many or implement these
projects and improvement opportunities
on their own after we're gone
we work 100 in healthcare
and all of our consultants although they
come from different backgrounds some are
laboratory professionals some are
quality professionals some are
like industrial engineering come out of
manufacturing world but all of them are
trained in all of the legal compliant
and technical areas of health care
in terms of regulatory environment
we
typically our implementation strive for
sustainability and long-term success for
our clients uh we're not so much in it
for the short short-term uh improvement
but more about teaching people how to
use these tools
to succeed long term
currently where our primary focus is in
north america we have worked um in
europe we have worked in asia
and we're in latin america so we do have
global experience
this graphic really represents the
process excellence model that is
employed by johnson and johnson
and we we call this our hamburger
and it starts really with doing a
current state analysis
what we call value streams and we're
going to talk a little bit more about
value streams
in the next few slides but the model
looks like this we map the current state
we decide which problems we're solving
for
then we choose the appropriate tool six
sigma
for capable process lean for removing
waste and design excellence for building
systems that flow up front without
having to do rework
after we map the current state choose
the tools that we need
then we
deliver a vision of the future state
by uh taking out as much waste or
improving uh you know
upon defect rate and so forth and that
becomes future state then obviously
becomes the new current state and then
obviously we never rest so it's a
continuous loop of improvement
using a tool set based on
data collection using value stream
mapping
when we start with clients or start in a
laboratory
we
virtually a hundred percent of time we
start with lean lean is easier to learn
it's intuitive and it um captures a lot
of the
waste that's embedded in process
operations then we typically follow up
with six sigma and design work after we
implement and teach the lean concept so
i'm going to focus a little bit now on
lean basics and i think a lot of you
have uh you know over the last 10 years
10 years ago when you said lean in the
clinical lab no one knew what you were
talking about but today it's fairly
mainstream so i think
that many of you understand and know
some of these concepts so i decided to
keep this kind of light in terms of the
overview of lean
now there's so many different
definitions for lean or lean thinking
this one happens to be the one that i
like deliver what the customer wants the
right way the first time with no wait
times interruptions or barriers and
it sounds easy to do but in reality
there's always interruptions wait time
and barriers so lean thinking is all
about identifying those and eliminating
them from our process systems
now this is a very busy slide and i know
that you will not be able to read what
is in in each of these boxes but let me
at a very high level walk you through
this
many of you will recognize this as a
value stream map and normally when i do
these presentations i have a pointer and
i'm walking around the room and
hopefully engaging the audience so bear
with me while i walk us through this
virtually so in the upper left hand
corner it says supplier that's your raw
material in the upper right hand corner
that is finished good and that is what's
delivered to your supplier
upon
you know completing all the process
steps and so in our world of clinical
laboratory
our raw material is in order for a
laboratory test result
and our finished good is when that test
result gets delivered back to the
physician or whoever ordered the test
and so each box in this value stream
represents a process step that the
product must go through in order to be
given a uh or be turned into a finished
good and the physician and or patient
get their answer so typically uh the
process boxes in a laboratory value
stream might be there's an ordering step
that requires some computer i.t then
there's a receiving step and
that might require printing of labels or
collection of phlebotomy supplies
then there is a collection step
then there is a receiving uh the
specimen in the lab step and processing
it moving it into the analytical
departments and then there may be a step
uh based on the methodology chemistry a
process box for that a hematology a
coagular analysis and so forth then i
have the information released reviewing
the results be it auto verify or manual
uh release and then my result goes back
to my
physician
and patient waiting for the for the test
now you can't see this but
in each of these boxes there's some
small labeling and
first one says ct
cycle time how long does it take to do
that step
the next one says rate rate means how
many per hour so if i can collect 100
tubes an hour but i can only receive
50 tubes an hour then i have a
bottleneck in my process and those
bottlenecks are the little triangles
that are next to each box and they
represent the inventory in our case
inventory the specimens or tests uh
orders waiting to go through the system
and in order to become a finished good
and then there's also uh in each box an
f p y which represents first pass yield
first pass yield is if i send a hundred
tubes through step number one
and all hundred go through to step
number two then i have a hundred percent
first pass yield
if i have rework in those hundred tubes
if my labels aren't correct if my tubes
are incorrect if i have a compromised
sample
and it requires an intervention by a
human or an instrument
and i cannot
move that
then my first pass yield gets
compromised so if i send 100 tubes into
chemistry and 10 unneeded rework then
i've got a 90 first pass yield or a 10
defect rate
now typically the way organizations
manage and most management cultures
have individual
silos if you will
of
function and management for each so i
could have an i.t department an ordering
department i could have a collection
department i could have a specimen
receiving and processing department i
could have a chemistry department a
hematology department and so on each
with their own level of supervisory
staff and each with their own goal and
typically in management cultures and
layouts you see this in floor space
design as well i'll put those
elements in at different areas in my
floor space and what happens
is that we tend to sub optimize or the
people in any given process box will
work very hard to do their job and sub
optimize their process but no one is
looking at this in terms of a value
stream so for instance i think a classic
example of this is you know putting in a
new computer
or putting in a laboratory automation
system and not looking at the steps
before and after in the value stream and
what occurs is that in many cases we can
um spend lots of capitals lots of human
resource time but our customer doesn't
see a change what lean does is looks at
this globally we map the entire current
state from order
through resolve and understand where
where our
first pass yields wait times process
bottlenecks and
rate
issues occur
so that's a very high level look at
value stream mapping but it's literally
impossible to do lean to no lean or
understand lean without understanding
the value stream concept
so our lean mission is recognize and
identify waste
easy to do have the courage to call it
waste ah not so easy and have the desire
to eliminate it
and actually eliminate it oftentimes
very difficult in some um you know
operations and corporate cultures and
but we have to understand especially
given the reforms and the the um issues
we have globally in terms of getting
more health care to more people for for
fewer um you know for fewer dollars
we have to understand that waste just it
raises cost it has no real benefit and
it certainly threatens all of our jobs
and i have heard of two situations just
within the last 10 days where hospitals
have determined that it is cheaper to
send their laboratory work out and
outsource lab work all except for stats
because they can buy it cheaper than
they can make it so when when we say
threatens all of our jobs i think under
reform we'll see very much shifting of
volumes in terms of where lab tests get
run and quite honestly these
will go to those people that can provide
the highest quality at the lowest cost
and obviously with the fastest
turnaround times based on customer
demand
so
the reason why i like lean the reason
why volumetric
valuemetrics leads with lean is because
it's intuitive it's easy to understand
so lean defines value the term value
as what the customer wants if the
customer wants a rapid test result
with a high level of quality
in a short period of time
that's how value is defined in lean
and so we look through the value stream
and we say any activity that transforms
the material or information
into information the customer wants that
is value-added activity so if i go to
the bedside in a hospital and i draw a
patient and i transform the fluid in
their vein into a tube a specimen in a
tube that is a value-added activity
any activity that takes time or
resources but does not add to the
customer requirement is labeled as
non-value ad
activity and those non-value activities
are labeled as waste in lean now
there are really two
two there's eight types of waste but two
large buckets of waste one we're going
to call pure waste pure waste is
when um i am a machine an instrument
sitting idle an operator is sitting idle
a specimen is sitting on a countertop
idle
it's wait time it's pure waste and can
be eliminated then there are required
waste we must calibrate we must run qc
we have to do maintenance we have
regulatory issues and so forth those
things are all waste in the eyes of lean
and what the customer cares about but
clearly not in terms of what
laboratorians have to do to provide
their quality results so those wastes
are
they are required but can they be
minimized can they be moved can they be
done by some other person and so forth
so just to clarify the two
um
the two large buckets of waste we then
as we walk through the value stream
we
look for areas where there's over
production i've got some pictures of
this coming up in just a minute wait
times transportation excess motion
inventory where we keep it who has it is
it in the right place
excess or over processing
motion which you'll see as well in a
minute and then defects uh and that is
you know if we're doing stuff and then
it gets kicked back to us for rework and
the last and most important is the waste
of human potential if we have operators
doing a lot of you know walking back and
forth
searching for parts and tools running to
get inventory those types of things uh
our people our most important asset and
if we waste their time by poor design
that's a waste of time that they can be
spending problem solving or actually
moving uh work through the value stream
so here's some pictures of waste i won't
i won't go through each of these i think
many of you have seen like the
transportation um we actually and i
think many of you may have also
experienced in doing some of these we
call them spaghetti diagrams and
that is we look to see how far a product
travels
how many different interventions does it
go in a straight line front to back or
does it have to go around barriers for
flow
there's often significant opportunity
in terms of just pure moving things
around of changing walk patterns uh
changing layout and design of floor
space and so forth to take dramatic
reductions in transportation
inventory
where do we keep our supplies
uh do the operators have what they need
at the bench without stocking out
do we have supplies in the way of the
flow for our operators and so forth
in terms of product and people moving
through the lab
and so forth motion and that is all the
chaos that sometimes occurs when you get
you know eight or ten operators or 20 or
30 operators and hundreds or thousands
of specimens all moving around in one uh
laboratory at one given time
wait times we've talked about but the
key concept of lean is
what what's called single piece flow or
level loaded work
so uh what we
every time we batch we if we wait for 20
tubes or 30 tubes or 50 tubes the very
first tube in that batch has to wait for
all the other ones and that adds to
cycle time so we try and level load uh
the work to the smallest pots possible
batch size
over processing uh overproduction
defects intellect i think that is
safe to say if we draw extra tubes print
out extra labels
we pick and sort multiple steps we mix
and match um or we have to match up
labels with tubes over and over again
um
all those over production and over
processing things uh can virtually be
eliminated from a laboratory and the
intellect which we've already touched on
so i'll move on
so here's how we do it
first of all we use the same approach
regardless of where we go we assess for
base condition and that's basically a
value stream map
we build a business case the business
case doesn't always have to be dollars
or
revenue or money but it can be um you
know capacity gain quality improvement
and so forth as suggested we start with
lean before we attack variation with six
sigma and we do these in projects the
projects can go from anywhere from six
to as long as fourteen weeks and we try
and and you know
get a big win so that we can earn
respect in the organizational culture
we use your team we select team members
so it's your subject matter experts and
so it's your your department your
instruments your floor space your
people it's not our boilerplate design
we actually use all of your data with
all of your current state we simply
bring the consultant with the toolset
and we very much engage senior
management we create a steering
committee that meets with the team once
a week and rounding with the purpose or
and you know sometimes you hear this in
the japanese term gemba walk or going to
where the process is
there's not a lot of office based stuff
here we get executives out rounding and
looking at where the work occurs and
talking to the people who work at the
bench level
and then we meticulously walk through
the value stream by mapping the product
product can be a patient by the way if i
have a patient going through surgery a
patient going through the emergency room
or uh you know through radiology
so it's whatever product we're dealing
with at the time then we look at the
activity of the operators how many
people how many touch points
does it take to get that product through
the value stream we look at facility
layout
department layout and design
does it enhance the flow of the product
and operator or does it or that does it
create barriers to flow
we look at inventory where it's kept
how it's managed we look at tools are
they in order of use do i have what i
need is my work space not cluttered up
with tools that i don't need
visual management systems that tell me
if i'm normal or abnormal at any given
time
what standards exist another real
cornerstone concept of lean thinking
is standard work standard work means if
i have 10 people doing a job we're going
to find the one best way to do that job
and then we'll train all 10 people to do
it in that one best way
and finally performance measures what's
being measured who's held accountable
and how can i see it real time
when we follow this model these are the
typical results we get these are not
extraordinary results these are typical
results over 10 or 12 years of
implementing these projects we reduce
turnaround times we cut turnaround times
in half
we reduce floor space requirements often
as high as 40 sometimes even higher
improved capacity and productivity of
the department in many cases we have the
same or fewer people with the same or
fewer instruments in the same or less
floor space doing 20 30 40 percent more
work not by working harder or faster but
by eliminating the barriers to flow
we have huge reductions in the time it
takes to reduce inventory or to manage
inventory and in many cases often have
pretty significant reductions in
inventory as well
increased quality obviously comes with
financial savings and a much anybody
that's walked through one of these lean
labs will tell you it's organized it's
quiet it's manageable
it's easy on your eye
so let's just walk through a very quick
case study this particular case study is
in northern michigan in the upper
peninsula of michigan it's marquette
general hospital in marquette michigan
and they have pretty typical it's about
a little over 300 bed community based
hospital but part of a network
and
actually was recently acquired by a
larger health system but there's a huge
uh outreach the management lab john
rhodes and
the pathology staff up there had created
a fairly significant outreach business
and so as the lab had grown over time
obviously they had some performance
issues and they want to keep growing and
and because they could go out and
acquire more clients but they were out
of space and their um
was very challenging in terms of the
number of people and instruments very
crowded uh and so forth and you can see
pretty typical turnaround times they
measured turnaround time for outreach
for inpatient and for stats and um you
know they're pretty typical the stats
they try to get through in an hour the
inpatients
you know tried to get them through in 90
minutes and then the outreach is
basically whenever they could get to it
a very high level of variability some
you know you when you look at the
variability graphs around this uh each
of these categories could spike up to
much longer cycle times so these are
averages
lots of process variation and it seemed
like a lot of time spent just
firefighting working on um
solving problems from a firefighting
mentality
so
um john and his team decided that they
would automate um they weren't
comfortable
they had asked
management for more space to relocate
the lab to a larger footprint and there
was no space and the capital investment
was too high so they decided to invest
in an automation system and
well i'll just go to the picture because
it's easier to see from the picture
so you see that
the automation system was placed in the
middle of the floor and it was in a loop
so that the instruments were clustered
around the outside of the track and in
order to fit that automation system in
the lab for chemistry hematology coag
and your analysis were pushed as uh as
you look at the slide off to the left so
the specimens come from the right upper
right hand corner uh where it says
specimen processing and then hematology
ag in your analysis or far left with the
automation loop in the center of the
floor
now all the machines all the instruments
all the people everyone who is
functioning well but the layout of the
of the lab did not facilitate a flow it
was very challenging to get uh people
and specimens through to the different
departments especially uh heme and koi
that were pushed to the back so the lean
team after a
several weeks of value stream mapping
and identifying opportunities where
bottlenecks and flow bottlenecks could
be improved and flow improved
they
broke the automation system down and
created this lean core cell
and so you'll see the automation change
from a loop in the center of the floor
to an l-shaped design that ran along the
wall
and hematology coag and your analysis
were pulled into the cellular design
this is a key concept in lean these uh
u-shaped or cell
lean cell designs are very key to flow i
want my operator to be working flowing
around the inside of the cell not having
to run laps around the outside
so you see some pictures this is the
before and after the before is on the
left you see the automation loop in the
center of the floor you see that wall to
the right really had some countertop
instruments but basically was waste in
lean speak it was wasted square feet and
so the team determined that much of that
stuff could be moved or completely
eliminated as it was kind of dead stock
and old manuals and books and so forth
and so they utilized that wall to create
a cellular design which is on the left
hand
side of the after picture
so you see the input station for the
automation system you'll see uh on the
right which is hard to see in this
picture but well i think we'll see one
coming up uh is where heme coag and your
analysis were pulled into the cell
now if you look at flow if you think
about flow of product and flow of
operator
before lean that the prime real estate
in the lab
was eaten up by the inside of the loop
of the automation
nothing it was pure wasted space in lean
speed
after lean you will see that that prime
real estate that large rectangle that
exists in every laboratory
was utilized for flow and now you the
picture here shows a single operator
operating seven instruments and uh it's
a little hard to see
but um all of
the out of cycle or all of the non-um
flow work
is moved outside so there's no
interruptions for the operator as well
as the flow of the product so all blood
gases and manual hematology are to the
left of the after lean picture
and there's actually uh the person who
does manual hematology there's a light
that comes on when a stat blood gas
comes in and that person's person flexes
over to the blood gas station and at the
very
end of the cell
against the far back wall you will see
an individual there that is actually
reviewing and releasing results so the
the operator in the cell does not even
own that function
for all those tests that are not
auto verified
the operator that reviews and releases
results is not in the cell
impeding the flow of specimen or
operator they're outside the cell doing
that function
now you can see what happened to
turnaround times you probably can't read
this so i'll just paraphrase it for you
but
the red is stat
the green is inpatient and the blue is
outpatient and you remember the
turnaround times prior to the lean
project were all high levels of
variability and anywhere from 60 minutes
to well over two hours and as the
flow of this core cell was created and
lean
flow implemented in the specimen
processing area guess what all the
samples become pretty much the same
thing because a chemistry or a
hematology or a coag sample regardless
of whether it's inpatient outpatient or
stat it's basically the same instrument
and the same test so you'll see that um
turnaround times all came down into that
uh stat uh red line was at 36 minutes
when this data was taken
they now john now has this lab um all
these basic core lab tests um are uh
received in and out of the lab and most
of them are under 30 minutes i think the
average
cycle time was 29 minutes the last time
we checked the data
and you'll see this uh some of the
project there the thing i included this
slide because i wanted to show the
savings in square feet 500 square feet
and the change in labor allocation
from 32 to 28 ftes now two ftes
retired and were not replaced they were
lost through attrition but the other two
they had been asking for a client
services operation staffed by med tax
and they
repeatedly did not have the budget and
could not get the cfo to approve head
count to staff client services so as a
result of the lean project they took two
people out of floor operations and put
in staff client services which made a
huge impact took all the telephone calls
out of the lab
so now
in the next few minutes that's your
basic lean overview value stream mapping
understanding where the wait times over
processing bottlenecks excess motion the
waste of lien are in your value stream
putting a team together to
eliminate that waste
then once eliminated
putting control systems and visual
management systems in place to ensure
that your changes will sustain and not
revert back to the old current state and
then developing a
tool set using the lean tools to to do
continuous improvement so that our time
is invested not in firefighting but
actually doing continuous improvement
projects that is lean thinking or lean
culture in
you know summarize
now i'd like to spend a few minutes just
talking about the different programs
that valuemetric services owns that
enable our ocd customers and clients to
really uh use these tools and to teach
themselves how to make improvements and
and how we developed this as a system
that really uh turns a customer into a
partner and turns our our business
relationship
into a win-win situation
so this graphic basically labeled
continuum of services talks about how as
the level of partnership between us ocd
value metrics and our customers goes up
so can the level of performance gains
achieved and so at the bottom of the
scale you'll see a product solution
which is really our what we believe to
be best in class world-class instruments
automation systems for both clinical lab
and transfusion medicine and
that's the the base of the of the scale
if you will and then we move into a
program that we have branded as p3
solutions and the three p's in p3 stand
for process
product and people and it's really the
integration of those three things
process product and people
into the most uh effective or productive
system that we can provide for you and
this p3 program which i have a slide
coming up describes it in a little more
detail
we do not charge for that it's a
value-added service you have to be
within a certain volume and instrument
configuration
class of trade and we
use it primarily uh if we have current
customers or if we have customers that
are considering a switch from another
vendor
we use it as a baselining and
improvement
vehicle to establish a baseline help the
customer not just acquire instruments
but
operate them in the most effective way
possible
and then the top level of partnering
really is a new program for us that
we've branded as ortho laboratory
excellence solutions
and this laboratory excellence program
uses our full value stream consulting
model
and it actually it's the one where we
transfer knowledge but something new and
something different and i think
not yet tried in clinical laboratory is
that we are willing and able to
guarantee outcomes and so i'll talk a
little bit more about the lab excellence
program and our ability to guarantee
these types of lean outcomes in the next
in the next few slides
so first the p3 as i discussed it's an
integrated approach that um looks at
process creating a smooth flow of
specimens supplies and information
product optimizing the use of
instruments and technology and obviously
people and that is how when how can we
have operators
doing more productive work and taking
some of the waste out of the operators
environment
and it looks something like this it
starts with a week one week on really
the front end to understand your current
state and during that week we uh we
collect data
we do observation we create an analysis
we look at those things that that follow
our standard lean model it's the flow of
the specimens the operators and how many
times they have to interact and touch
and how in the cycle times what your
current layout is
and how it might be helping support flow
or might be impeding flow
we deliver a report
and some actionable findings and
recommendations and
relative to the process to layout and
you know the instruments and so forth
and this also gives us both us and our
customer client a baseline set of
metrics by which we can measure future
gain
then after the new instruments or the
new footprint or the new lab design has
been installed
we come back if it's a complex um you
know if it's a relatively if it's
instruments only it's for a week if it's
a automation lab or a highly complex lab
uh we may come for two weeks but in the
second week we we develop standardized
work processes for the operators we look
at pre-analytical areas and and make
sure that the specimens flow from
receiving lab all the way through the
analytical area and also we develop
operator workstations for standard work
as
described before we help with reagent
replenishment guidelines inventory
management if you will
and we do lean awareness training so
our goal is then
to deliver that new current state
and measure that versus the baseline of
the old current state um in terms of
space labor turn on time uh optimization
and so forth and then typically
somewhere four to six months later we
will come and do an audit which
basically
is designed to see how well you're doing
to bring you
back if there's some uh productive
correction or to get you to the next
level if you've grown and gotten better
and better
that's our p3 program once again it's
value added it's part of doing business
with ortho clinical diagnostics
now let's talk about laboratory
excellence solutions and what basically
this is is our full service our full
value stream consulting model it's a
solutions program that we offer to
customers and it really focuses on
outcomes
what we're looking for
is to guarantee
those outcomes and we'll actually put a
consulting agreement right in with our
product agreement
and so it becomes one really
and we will in that service agreement
we'll look at whatever outcomes we agree
upon based on a baseline or baseline set
of metrics that we've collected uh in
our current state so if your goal is to
reduce turnaround times
to optimize the use of your floor space
to reduce your total operating cost
to expand your operation
you know through capacity increases
any of those potential outcomes
can become part of the solutions concept
and embedded in our consulting agreement
that we will actually guarantee the mon
and and
we're so sure that we can hit those if
we follow our model that we will put a
half of our consulting fees
against milestone payments and once so
basically what we do is you know part of
our fee covers the training and having
our consultant on site and doing the you
know upfront based condition work
and then the rest of it is all tied to
you achieving the milestones or the
outcomes you want and you basically
don't pay until we achieve the metrics
that were agreed upon
in the
in the milestone contract
it's a very collaborative approach so it
starts with assessment
we develop a scope of services what it
is we're trying to accomplish and what
it is
you're trying to accomplish
we embed that
list of milestones in an agreement
then we send our consultant on site go
and work with you as you go through the
program and then we measure our impact
over time and we do not stop until we
achieve the milestones
as agreed upon in our contract
now we have a website you'll see the web
address coming up very shortly
we have case studies for these p3
solutions
we also have
case studies for our transformational
outcome or full value stream projects
and
i think
our website i'll leave this slide up for
just a few minutes for those of you that
would like to capture the website
and these case studies can be downloaded
and also our contact if you'd like to
contact us and get more information or
talk to
some of our clients who have been
through the programs we're more than
happy to provide that information
so with that
i will close
and uh
if you'd like more information my email
address is here
and as is
jamie miles and i actually believe it or
not see a typo in my email address you
need to put an s
in front of
f-r-i-e-d-l-a so it's s free law at
its.jnj.com but i can also be reached
through our web page and jamie is
the an executive principal with
viometric services uh and he is the
co-leader of our group
and can also uh answer lots of questions
if you'd like to reach out to us
so with that i will close
and open for question and answers if
there are any questions feel free to
click on the q a tab and i'll try and
answer them as best i can
one other thing i'd like to mention is
that um
i have established a chat room
on the bio conference live website it is
available and i'll be checking it for
the next hour online so if you'd like to
establish a chat
i'm more than willing to do that as well
also our facilitator don will be putting
up a link
very shortly to the ce credit
up so that you can
get your ce credit for attending the
conference
so at this point i do not see any
questions i'll stay on for just another
few minutes uh if there are questions
i'll be happy to answer and i'll be
checking the chat site uh with you know
frequently in the next hour
i want to thank everybody for joining
and if you'd like more information feel
free to get in touch with us
and i see that don has put the link to
the bio conference
uh ce web
website up
so i think everybody can see that at
this point
so
you